you go too far in the direction of
performance performance performance you
build an organization filled with
mercenaries that will stab each other in
the back to hit numbers and hit personal
rewards um if you slide the uh too far
the other direction you know you have a
hippie commune where everybody loves
each other but no work gets done and
there's no accountability and and this
is the hard part about leadership which
is it's it's it's it's like marriage
it's like friendship it's like children
which is you'll never be on the path
you're constantly blocking and tackling
and trying to make it work but what
makes it work over the course of time is
that strong Foundation of trust that
when you screw up or get it wrong or
you're grumpy or you're tired that
people are patient with you um and it's
just viewing people as human beings and
bringing empathy to work now usually
when I talk about these themes um you
know people find them uncomfortable now
I know this is women in leadership that
we're talking to and I will say that
women understand my work better than men
you know I talk about the stuff and
women tend to go yeah and men tend to
say do you have any case studies you
know and uh uh so when I talk about
bringing empathy to work there's nothing
there's nothing mushy or weak about this
I I'll give you a simple example um uh
here's a fairly normal scenario you know
a manager walks into one of their
reports office and says hey I've noticed
your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before if you don't pick up
your numbers in the fourth quarter I
don't know what's going to happen right
that's a fairly common scenario here's
that same scenario with empath
injected hey um I noticed your numbers
are down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay I'm worried about you what's
going on that's empathy injected into
into leadership were you actually
concerned about the person rather than
the than than missing the number and
what you'll find is people will open up
ask for help tell you what the
challenges are maybe they have struggles
at home maybe they've been put in a
position where they don't actually have
the training to do the job there's a
wealth of things that we can support and
help and by the way when do that not
only does it build trust but um it
actually helps the performance because
we can help we know what the what the
root of the with the problem is and so
we need more of that at work in order to
produce High performing teams you know
when I talk about high performing teams
and I looked at some of the most the
highest performing tees you know in the
world what you'll find is deep deep deep
levels of trust love and
camaraderie